una partícula se mueve sobre el eje x la
función x dt indica la posición de la
partícula en cualquier tiempo t mayor o
igual que 0 aquí está la fórmula cuál es
la velocidad de dt de la partícula ente
igualados pausa en el vídeo y traten de
responder por su cuenta aquí lo
importante es darnos cuenta de que la
velocidad es una función del tiempo y es
la derivada de la posición calculamos la
derivada con respecto a t de esta
función la derivada de t al cubo con
respecto a t estrés por t al cuadrado y
si esto no les resulta familiar los
invito a que repasen la regla de la
potencia la derivada de -4 por t al
cuadrado con respecto a t es menos 8 t
la derivada de 3 t con respecto a t es
más 3 y la derivada de una constante no
cambia con respecto al tiempo por lo que
es igual a cero con esto encontramos la
función en velocidad con respecto al
tiempo y si queremos conocer la
velocidad de la partícula cuando t es
igual a 2
simplemente sustituimos t por 2 en esta
función lo que nos da 3 x 2 al cuadrado
por 4 es 12 menos 8 por 2 es menos 16
mar 3 es igual a menos 1 y pueden pensar
que este menos 1 no parece una velocidad
pero si nos dijeran las unidades como
que te está en segundos y equis en
metros entonces la posición estaría en
metros y la velocidad sería menos un
metro por segundo
también puede que se pregunten qué
significa este signo negativo quiere
decir que la partícula se mueve hacia la
izquierda recordemos que ésta se mueve
sobre el eje x si la velocidad es
negativa significa que x disminuye y la
partícula se mueve a la izquierda
cuál es la aceleración adt de la
partícula ente igual a 3 de nuevo pausa
en el vídeo y traten de responder a esta
pregunta en este caso tenemos que darnos
cuenta de que la aceleración como
función del tiempo es la derivada de la
velocidad y a su vez es la segunda
derivada de la posición va a ser igual a
la derivada de esto la derivada de tres
por t al cuadrado con respecto a t es
igual a 6 por t la derivada de menos 8 t
con respecto a t
-8 y la derivada de la constante es 0
tenemos 68 la aceleración de la
partícula cuando t es igual a 3 va a ser
igual a 6 por 3 que es 18 menos 8 lo que
nos da 10 positivo cuál es la dirección
del movimiento de la partícula ente
igual a 2 izquierda-derecha ninguna ya
habíamos mencionado esto pero de todas
maneras pausa en el vídeo piensen y
respondan por su cuenta este signo de
aquí indica la dirección de la partícula
cuando tenemos un signo negativo en la
velocidad significa que el movimiento es
a la izquierda así que elegimos la
opción ente igual a 3 la rapidez de la
partícula incrementa disminuye o no
cambia pausa en el vídeo y tratan de
responder esta pregunta aquí debemos ser
cuidadosos porque si el enunciado
menciona que la velocidad de la
partícula se incrementa disminuye o no
cambia entonces sólo tendríamos que ver
la aceleración y si la aceleración es
positiva entonces habríamos que la
velocidad está incrementando
pero en el enunciado no preguntan por la
velocidad sino por la rapidez y
recordemos que la rapidez es la magnitud
de la velocidad por ejemplo para t
igualados la velocidad es menos 1 y si
las unidades fueron metros y segundos
sería menos un metro por segundo pero la
rapidez es de un metro por segundo en la
rapidez no nos interesa la dirección así
que no tomamos en cuenta el signo así
pues para saber si la rapidez incrementa
o disminuye o no cambia si la
aceleración es positiva y la velocidad
es positiva entonces la magnitud de la
velocidad incrementa lo que significa
que la rapidez incrementa también si la
velocidad es negativa y la aceleración
también es negativa entonces quiere
decir que también la rapidez incrementa
pero si la velocidad y la aceleración
tienen signos diferentes quiere decir
que la rapidez disminuye pues va a
disminuir la magnitud de la velocidad
veamos la velocidad cuando t es igual a
3 usamos esta fórmula y nos queda 3 por
3 al cubo que es
7 - 24 3
todo esto es igual a 6 observamos los
signos de la velocidad y la aceleración
y notamos que son iguales podríamos
decir que van en la misma dirección ya
que ambos son positivos así que la
velocidad se va a volver más positiva
cada vez o también podemos decir que la
magnitud de la velocidad va a
incrementar así que la rapidez
incrementa si la velocidad fuera
negativa / igual a 3
entonces la rapidez disminuiría porque
la velocidad y la aceleración irían en
direcciones opuestas nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo